you're a really smart guy
your team is real smart shout out to tk
what are you doing um
you know the real estate market is
booming there's so much [ __ ] going on
are you putting your money in any
different spots
or you're just buying more jewelry
because i this is a lot more jewelry
than the last time i
i'm putting more into stocks and like
[ __ ] like that this this [ __ ] i'll be
trying to tell me
i'll be born by a little you feel me
dropping a hundred two hundreds
everybody
you know little bitcoin this [ __ ] got
the money gonna buy a whole bitcoin like
you could buy it i don't even know how
many bitcoins you could get with that go
on dodge queen go crazy
oh yeah yeah yeah he don't want to eat
that'd be like this [ __ ] crazy i told
him he can go buy like
go drop 20 on a couple little houses and
get aaron b to be the [ __ ]
to keep rolling his eyes right now
[Laughter]
hey man so i mean look it's your money
you're gonna do what you want with you
can't hey i tell you what you can't take
it with you
that's i mean that's some real [ __ ] your
family good you're good you're
comfortable as long as you're happy
but so you're you're [ __ ] with the
the crypto yeah i'll be [ __ ] around
i don't know how to work it i'll just be
throwing little fifties and things right
right right let's see what happens with
it what happened
i should be lighting up all green though
oh my [ __ ] everything it'd be like 15
greens and like three oranges
that's all i know i know i'm winning you
know robert robin hood yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey shout out to robin
hood because that [ __ ] just made it so
easy
it's like a [ __ ] it's like a social
media app you just log on
like you're buying
yeah i just put 10 vans into stocks and
[ __ ] i'm like
hey that's hey but that's good no it's
good but [ __ ] i feel like
this is going to be overloading the
system or something there's going to be
a glitch somewhere
they ain't going to want us to win that
much we got to get drunk
hey draco don't miss it though draco you
got to get you got to get in the bed and
at least a little bit in that bitcoin
game
i was thinking about it
yeah but [ __ ] it's just you gonna have
it over there you're gonna have it over
there bro if you if you drop the draco
uh nft fan
you'll make a million bro like that's
something y'all y'all got it
bro so uh tory lanez just did it and and
he's quote unquote canceled and that
[ __ ] went crazy
like you know what i'm saying i'm not
saying i can't i'm just saying like you
know the
industry is canceled tori tori good
people
but but he did the nft and and uh i
think he did like one point something a
million like
dude he cracked him even if you do a 500
off of something that isn't even real
it's like nothing you can touch it's
literally like a digital
bro you could drop a song as an nft
and just how does that work you i i'll
connect you with some people my boy did
does all of the uh
nft [ __ ] for uh a lot of the but yeah
yeah you could like literally you could
tell your fans i'ma put out a song
as an nft and there's gonna be one of
one
so the only one person will have the
song
they have to buy that nft and the bids
will go up like six free i promise you
bro
a hundred percent man
uh